my problem with the whole
psychic thing in the tarot cards is that
my experience with these psychic
type people is that is that most of them
are at least in my experience they're
full of [ __ ]
and they're hustlers some of them are
absolutely and and
whenever i hear that kind of stuff i
kind of start i kind of it just
it inclines me to dismiss whatever is
going on around it because i
they're for the most part you know
you'll get probing questions or the sort
of guess
about things based on your appearance or
your life or whatever and they'll keep
going that
going down that way by setting probing
questions don't you get
i mean don't you ever get the sense that
some of these people that are reaching
out to you
they just that they're familiar with
your research they're familiar with your
story so they know if they come up with
something that's similar
to what your to what your expertise is
and what you've been studying
for 15 years that
you know it's kind of like the same
thing they're just kind of trying to
mirror your story or trying to come up
with
there's no there's no real hard proof of
any of this stuff it's just hearsay
right
well there's multiple witness cases
right so two people see something at the
same time both people have to be lying
in that
in those situations right but when it
comes to psychic abilities you can't
really
sure you can test those oh yeah you can
prove those you can test those how could
you prove that do you just do a
laboratory experiment talk to a dean
raiden there's a
researcher out of california dean rayden
he's written a bunch of books
he he worked for um bell labs i think
and he worked on some of the uh
sri which is uh the remote viewing that
the government did i think he was
slightly involved with that
yeah so that it can be you can study
that it's not 100
it's difficult to study but you can you
can there's a
um there's a you can get results through
scientific
measures it's it's totally ignored
within the sciences except the people
that are doing this they're coming up
with consistent results yeah what did he
find out about sri
lanka uh i can't remember what the
acronym is uh
he was involved with um there's a he's
involved with an organization called
ions which is
institute for noetic sciences which is
was was
broke away i think from sri and that was
stud that was started by
uh the astronaut edgar mitchell who was
one of the fellows who walked on the
moon
and when he came back from from the moon
he his job was to like land the craft on
the moon
right and so after he's after he did
that and like they're flying home his
job was done
so he didn't have to do anything so all
he could do is just look out the window
you know you're like looking out the
window for a week and this you're out in
space and
he said he had like what amounted to a
mystical experience he's he's a um
he's a physicist from mit and he had
this
magical mystical blissful experience
like looking out into the heavens which
makes sense right
right of course you're riding through
outer space yeah so he has a so and he
he came back and he said like you know
he talked to some people and said look
this up i had this mystical experience
he tried to describe it and these people
came back and said it's called
the closest thing we can find is it
called a samadhi experience
which is a feeling of oneness with the
magic of all i'm
paraphrasing that poorly and he said oh
okay well that's
that's what what what um
that's what i had so that's what i'll
call it and so he started this
organization that studies that dean
raiden is involved in that organization
so and you know i'm not a scientist so
i'm not i'm all i'm i'm a journalist
more than a scientist right so i'm not
trying to prove or disapprove anything
i'm trying to
to to collect enough stories
to to back up my
the hypothesis that was in a way thrust
into my lap
out of all these stories these these owl
stories these ufo stories
how many of them have like video or
photo or photos of these things
happening
like photos of of a craft or a light or
a being or
a giant owl so you mentioned like four
foot tall owls
okay i got no pictures of four foot tall
owls okay so
so the so i got a lot of pictures of
owls people
get send me pictures of owls all the
time right so the close-up
i'll like people say i've had ufo
contact and i'll land it on my back
porch here's the picture
it's an owl it looks like an owl on the
back porch the story is what more
important is
more important to me people will say
like i was called to get my camera and
go outside and take a picture in the
dark of the roof
and they do and there's an owl in the
picture so
you know i i'm cataloging those kinds of
stories
and i'm trying not to weight them too
much right because some of them are
pretty like loose you know
and but at the same time you see a
pattern you see that same story emerging
now your question was um
so i don't have any you know what i do
have i have a audio
there's a woman her name is um lindy
tucker
and she saw a flying craft a flying
saucer in her yard in
canada um orton ontario
and this would have been the 1970s and
she had a
audio recording she recorded the audio
of this
craft and the craft made this beeping
noise the craft doesn't sound like
anything it sounds like beep beep beep
beep
not that interesting right but along
with that
noise there's a hooting of an owl in the
background so
like there's that's like for me that was
like gold for a little like oh my god
there's an owl and a ufo
now what has since happened is she has
collected other people who have recorded
ufos and they they make this beep
beep beep beep noise now
that was there was a point in the 70s
when that noise was
kind of being reported that has tapered
off not many people are reporting that
steady beeping noise anymore
but she collected i can't remember
multiple
audio recordings of flying saucers and
they all made this
completely it sounds like a truck
backing up it's not that interesting but
given the the the witness testimony
taking that into account if it's to be
believed and
nobody is i mean yes there's certainly
people out there hoaxing
there's certainly people out there
stretching the truth but
um i'm looking for the pattern in the in
the overall stories
yeah it's just like
it's hard it's hard to create a pattern
when everyone's aware
of all of the information that you're
getting because you're publishing it all
right so so not all of it but yeah not
all but a lot of it right
so so the people that are sending you
these stories that they're able to go
and read
through all your blog posts about hun i
mean how many stories have you published
on your blog post about owls and ufos
many hundreds yeah so they're they have
access to these so it's
it's kind of like but it's like yeah i
don't i
i see where you're going with this but
my sense strongly is that people are
contacting me for another reason
they're contacting me so like you have a
conversation with someone they're like
i need to talk to you like i had this
experience like i'm thera i'm playing
the role of a therapist i'm not a
therapist but i'm playing the role of it
because these people are
freaked out okay so they're
they're not looking for any fame they're
not looking for any money they want to
be
they want to have a pseudonym if they're
ever if i document this stuff in a book
these people are not at peace this is
they are freaked out by their
experiences they're asking me for help
they're saying like have you ever heard
of anything like this happening i'm like
yeah it's actually what you've described
is very common
so so i'm i'm not looking for
proof in a way i'm i'm hoping to offer
some solace to the people who are having
these experiences
now you talked to you talk about a
psychic who you talked to her name was
anya briggs yes can you explain who anya
briggs is and explain what your
experience was with her which which
which experiences
there's something about grey aliens she
saw or she saw aliens dancing around you
or something like that
in in your book you talked about you
talked about she said
she could see aliens around you when she
was looking at you oh
okay yeah so she's psychic this is
something no like i don't take this as
concrete proof that there's aliens she
said there i don't think she did she
said dancing she may have she i don't
know if it was dancing but she said she
saw him around you
okay yeah so she this has happened to me
more than once where i've talked to
people who so in these waters
like i end up bumping into i i did one
radio interview and the guy
i said well you know you talk to a
shaman and they'll tell you stories
about
owls and they're like shaman who talks
to a shaman i'm like you write a book
about owls
shamans come and find you you'll start
talking to shamans so
so i'm like because of the book and
because of the researcher i'm
i'm interacting i'm talking with people
who are psychic
who claim to be psychic and one of the
things that i've had more than one
person say
they kind of look at me and they've
actually i've had one person kind of
look over my shoulder and kind of go
like
there's there's i say like
alien energy around you great alien
energy now
i i don't see it i don't sense it but
that's the kind of feedback i'm getting
i don't weight that too too much
but i do i am curious of the patterns
well and i'm interested why is it
always gray alien it's not it's not what
is a great like what is the difference
between
like are there any other color aliens
are they all gray no so
if you look so this is this is coming
from a wealth of research
okay so about
and i'm making these numbers up but
let's say of the pool of data
we've got 100 ufo reports where people
interact with being
50 or so will be grey aliens the gray
typical gray aliens that showed up on
the x-files that come out of the
mother ship at the end of skinny
humanoids
humanoids big heads bald heads big black
eyes big penetrating black eyes
um spindly long fingers about three and
a half to four feet tall
after that people will report
um humans total humans except
tall and somewhat oftentimes reported as
being like seven foot tall and beautiful
like superheroes basically and
um reptilians like giant
reptiles which is not uncommon in the
research
i'm only saying what i'm what's reported
so i haven't seen any of these things
and then giant praying mantises and then
there's a bunch of other things like
robots or
or light beings or balls of light and
things like that so yeah it's
the the the data that's out there and
it's
it's there's a lot of it there's a
wealth of data like people i've see
serious researchers are collecting this
data and the problem is like how do you
someone says you know i saw a giant
praying mantis how do you
how do you like
i mean just i mean yes it's a it's an
incredible story it's a story beyond
belief
but you hear that story 100 times
and and you have to take it seriously
i